let's say that you love to eat apples
and you are going to buy
a apples so a is the number of apples
number
of apples
but you also have a budget so you have
to care about cost so let's say c is
equal to the total cost
and let's say that the price of an apple
is two dollars so two dollars per
apple
there's several ways that we can express
the relationship between the total cost
and the number of apples
one way is if we solve for the total
cost and we say okay the total cost is
going to be two dollars per apple times
the number of apples so it's going to be
2
a
another way that we could rewrite this
if we were to divide both sides of this
by two we would get
that the number of apples
is equal to
cost
over two
these are equivalent expressions i
should say these are equivalent
equations but the way they've been
written make it useful for different
scenarios for example on the left hand
side here it's really easy to try out
different a's and then think about how
that will affect the cost
and so when it's written like this we
would call the variable that it's easy
to try out different values we would
call that the independent variable
independent
variable and then the one that we are
essentially solving for that we then
spit out a value after we compute using
the independent variable you call that
the dependent variable you could view it
as look in this situation the cost is
dependent on the number of apples you
choose to eat
now when we wrote it over here this
looks a little bit different now the
number of apples is solved for
and we compute how many apples based on
the cost so this would be a scenario
where you have a budget and you tell me
what the budget is and i could tell you
the number of apples so in this
situation c is the independent variable
and since we have solved for a a is the
dependent variable this is useful if i
give you a number of apples and you want
to know the total cost and this is
useful if you have a certain cost and
then i and then you want to find out the
number of apples